[Musik]
und herzlich willkommen hier heute zu
einer neuen episode minecraft mit luca
staffel 2 erstmal möchte ich mich für
die letzte episode entschuldigen denn da
habe ich gedacht dass das hier irgendwie
vielleicht auch ein anderer spieler sein
könnte irgendwas was durch diese mod
hinzugefügt wurde ist es allerdings
nicht obwohl mir zahlreich in die
kommentare geschrieben das ist ein
einwanderer es ist eigentlich genauso
wie ein skelett oder seine pfeile mich
halt verlangsamen können wir allerdings
ganz easy töten jetzt haben wir einen
bogen
oder auch nicht
ich habe aber ein pfeil im fuß und meine
spitzhacke ist gerade auch beim abbauen
dieses eisen es hier vorne kaputt
gegangen deswegen sage ich das mal ganz
schnell ein hier unten sind sogar noch
ein paar mehr eisen blöcke jetzt haben
was allerdings alles abgebaut und ich
würde sagen dass wir uns an der stelle
jetzt auch mal rüber bewegen zu dem dorf
was wir zum ende der letzten episode
entdeckt haben hier vornehmlich das
verortete fleisch auch nochmal mit
generell erst mal zu beginn immer in
minecraft alles mitnehmen was man
irgendwie kriegen kann auch die kohle
hier vorne zehn stunden später ich habe
einfach hier gerade überall so viel
kohle abgebaut dass die sonne da hinten
schon untergeht und ich diese restliche
kohle gar nicht mehr aufnehmen kann
deswegen werde ich das jetzt mal alles
einfach hier fixum solchen kohleblöcke
verwandeln und wir schon lokis bewegen
uns dann jetzt auch so langsam rüber zu
dem dorf dort hinten hier vorne ist
wieder so ein bisschen ein ähnliches
billionen wie noch in der letzten bzw
vorletzten folge mit diesen ganzen
komischen kürbissen und so jedoch sind
hier halt keine kürbisse sondern einfach
nur kleine bäumchen das sieht auf jeden
fall sehr süß aus das dorf gerade weil
das ja auch an seinem kleinen fluss
gelegen ist bei den bergen und so und
hier vorne auch sonnenwald ist mit auch
ein bisschen schnee ich habe ehrlich
gesagt meine sachen von dahinten von
mein base zu holen und mich hierhin zu
bauen weil ich es hier ehrlich gesagt
deutlich schön auf den wir haben eine
katze wir haben ja auch irgendwie höhlen
tatsächlich und wir haben halt direkten
dorf na gut ich würde jetzt erstmal ein
bettchen nehmen dass hier hinstellen und
eine runde schlafen gehen um dann
entdecken wir jetzt am nächsten tag
direkt mal unser kleines dörflein hier
vorne und versuchen und so ein bisschen
mit den dorfbewohnern anzufreunden also
wen haben wir denn hier beispielsweise
so alles am start wir schauen erst mal
dass wir hier vorne chronologisch
angefangen also da ist
wieder so ein stinktier
aber auch in die kommentare geschrieben
dass das ja eigentlich war sperren sind
für mich sind faule stinktiere aber gute
freunde das ist auf jeden fall das erste
häuschen hier haben wir eine kiste am
start in der wir einige kartoffeln haben
wir haben süß bären und wir haben
kürbiskerne die benötigen wir wirklich
nicht wären wirklich genügend kürbisse
wir fordern ist nichts mehr ich weiß
nicht was das hier für komische haben
wir schon wieder ein paar hunde ich weiß
wirklich nicht was diese ganzen
steinblöcke überall suchen allerdings
laufen denn jetzt mal rein in das
dörflein die richter das land hier ist
schon
und lass mein haus in ruhe ich wollte
mir das eigentlich nur mal
gucken hat mit obliegt ihr
okay
und mir nicht
okay wir machen seine töne vorne mal
wieder zu und gehen weiter ins nächste
häuschen das haben wir nämlich hier
vorne sondern mit so zwei pflanzen nach
vorm start jetzt auch nichts
lass meine sachen in ruhe
auf wiedersehen
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht was
hier liegen lassen soll ich das mal ein
feiner langsamkeit hier liegen dem
brauch ich glaub ich nicht die smaragde
nehme ich mit fichtenstämmen haben wir
auch genug brote sind wichtig und
kartoffeln sind wichtig dann haben wir
müssen was zu essen und kartoffel können
wir auch weiter wieder anpflanzen
deswegen laufen wir jetzt mal ganz
schnell wieder weiter bevor irgendwer
das merkt hier fordert wir wollen es ja
dann eingesperrt ich hab den eingesperrt
weil er ein vollidiot ist
ich bin auch ein vollidiot lol
okay wir schauen erst mal in das gebäude
hinein hier ist eine stein säge das ist
wirklich sehr sehr geil die benötigen
wir aktuell allerdings erst mal nicht
mehr steigern alle die sich da mal nicht
auskennt ist ich kann hier steine
reinpacken dann muss ich beispielsweise
bei der bruch steintreppe das nicht
immerhin legen und ich spare auch
deutliche deutlich eine menge ressourcen
allerdings benötige ich das jetzt
erstmal nicht wir schauen jetzt erstmal
ob wir hier vielleicht noch irgendwo ein
paar kisten finden hier vorne ist ein
lesepult ok und mit ihm hier können wir
theoretisch auch handeln wenn wir ihm
einfach papier geben und dann kann er
uns vielleicht ein paar bücher geben ich
lasse ihnen erst mal hier sind
bücherregale das ist auch sehr sehr geil
denn erst mal hier weil ich mich zum
ende der heutigen episode hier so ein
bisschen hin bauen möchte das dorf ist
tatsächlich größer als gedacht wir vorn
ist auch noch eine kleine kiste am start
mit einem fan
ich lasse auch öfters mal einen fahren
wo ich es halt einfach meinen kanal
löschen hier haben wir jetzt auf jeden
fall so ein riesiges loch wo wir uns
einfach mal an der seite so ein bisschen
drumherum runter bauen müssen ich weiß
nicht warum hier ist die glocke
und hier ist
eine höhle gut wir laufen hier an der
seite jetzt einfach mal hoch und schauen
dass wir das dorf von hier noch ein
bisschen entdecken können und dann
gucken wir auch direkt hier vorne mal in
die bude rein die haben nämlich auch
direkt die kiste ich glaub ich hab noch
nie im dorf gesehen wo so viele kisten
am start band zwei eisen klumpen brauche
ich jetzt wirklich nicht ich habe glaube
ich genug eisen allerdings haben wir
hier auf jeden fall noch eine kleine
hütte und ich denke mal dass es das
jetzt auch war hier oben ist der glaube
ich nichts mehr außer seinen fällt also
ich habe dieses dorf bereits vor vier
tagen entdeckt
hier kann ich noch mal kurz das weizen
mitnehmen und mehr haben wir hier
tatsächlich dann auch nicht ich bin aber
ganz ehrlich freunde mich turnt das
alles hier schon sehr an die tatsache
dass wir hier eine menge villiger haben
mit denen wir handeln können die auch
noch alle keinen richtigen beruf haben
also wir können alle von der berufung
her noch ändern und hier vorne mit dem
wald das feiere ich auch ziemlich krass
dass wir hier quasi die gleichen
möglichkeiten haben in unserer welt
hinten nach vorne so auch schnee von
daher habe ich mir ist gerade einmal so
grobe überlegt erhabene er fliegt
eigentlich schon in die richtige
richtung meine lieben freunde wir
bewegen uns zurück zu unserer pace und
werden denke ich direkt mal umziehen nur
wenige minuten später ich bin gerade von
da vorne bis hierhin gelaufen und mir
ist dann gerade aufgefallen dass es
vielleicht sogar meisten sinn macht wenn
ich hier einfach mal kurz natur
hinsetzen ein paar sachen hier rein
packe das wenn ich da ich hatte meine
ganzen items mit nehme ich zumindest
noch ein bisschen mehr platz im inventar
habe
oh
[Musik]
mein gott
gestraft unnormal erschrocken
auf einmal sind die so echt
[Musik]
und wie
der scheint allerdings zu machen
[Musik]
hey leute ich hab ich eine ganz normale
teilnimmst karte eingeblendet wie ich
von da hinten gerade auf dem weg zu
meiner alten keller base bin glaube ich
dort vorne um die ecke irgendwo stehen
müsste die sache ist allerdings das
jetzt hier vorne kurz vorm ziel
plötzlich so ein bär und
welche auftauchen
ich weiß nicht was ich da falsch gemacht
habe dass der wm ich dann plötzlich
angegriffen hat ich habe ihn nicht
berührt
es gibt nicht den gleichen fehler
gemacht wie mit diesem komischen tieren
noch in der letzten folge wo ich die
einmal kurz berührt haben und dann sind
die direkt aus kassel losgelaufen ich
habe wirklich nichts gemacht die sache
ist allerdings dass wir hier vorne jetzt
auch schon in unserer base angekommen
sind und ich muss jetzt erst mal gucken
dass ich mal inventar was meistens
hauptsächlich leer ist gerade
irgendwas falsch
ich muss jetzt erstmal gucken welche
items ich wirklich mitnehmen also ich
hab jetzt diese sachen einfach mal
eingepackt und das hier sind die ganzen
sachen die ich jetzt einfach mal hier zu
hause gelassen habe ich weiß nicht ob
das jetzt dumm ist dass ich diese ganzen
sachen ich hier lasse und auch gefordert
dass ich die ganzen stein unteren einen
schmelzofen habe ich mir eingepackt die
sache ist allerdings dass ich wirklich
bock habe da hinten hin zu gehen weil
ich finde wir haben jetzt halt einfach
aktuell die möglichkeiten in dieser welt
weil wir nicht gezwungen sind weil wir
auf dem ozean sind dass wir dort bleiben
so deswegen will ich auch irgendwo hin
wo es hat wirklich geil dass deswegen
herrn sich noch mal ganz kurz die süße
beeren und ich würde auch sagen dass wir
uns dann direkt nach dort hinten hin
bewegen wir waren zwar noch nicht dort
hinten bei der hexe wir waren auch noch
nicht dort vorne da ist ja auch
irgendwie so was komisch das was ich gar
nicht so ich erkennen kann die sache ist
allerdings dass wir immer zu jeder zeit
zurückkehren können
diesen scheiß süß werden will ich
eigentlich gar nicht zurück allerdings
nun auf jeden fall eine ganz kurze time
nicht wie ich zurück laufe zum dorf
[Musik]
und da sind wir auch schon hier vorne in
unserem
jaich verlässlich sagen neuen zuhause
angekommen weil irgendwie ist mir gerade
auch aufgefallen die katze läuft ich
denke dass ich nicht weg kommt ne ja
irgendwie ist mir vorhin aufgefallen
dass es bei mir zu hause doch ein
bisschen schöner ist als hier vorne
sieht alles ein bisschen abgegrast hier
aus und auch hier vorne in die andere
richtung ist jetzt auch nicht alles
schön aus sondern erst ein bisschen
furchteinflößend mit dieser weite um den
ganzen steinen und so also ich weiß es
noch nicht so richtig ob ich mich hier
überhaupt zu hause fühle ich lege mich
jetzt einmal hier direkt zwischen die
beiden häuser mit meinem bettchen bzw
werde ich jetzt glaube ich auch erst mal
ganz kurz hinten zu meiner kiste
hingehen müssen weil ich ja dort hinten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich hätte doch eine kissing ist die ist
das
[Musik]
mein gott
ich dachte hat die kiste wer weg ich
würde einfach mal sagen dass wir das so
machen meine lieben freunde
ich stelle jetzt erstmal hier mein
bettchen hin ich werde jetzt auch hier
vorne meine werkbank die ich ja hier
vorn habe und einen schmelzofen habe ich
auch mitgenommen die teile kann ich
jetzt ja auch mal hier vorne hinstellen
und die ganzen sachen die ich hier habe
kann ich jetzt auch noch mal ganz kurz
in die kiste packen ich habe ja einen
stämme mitgenommen und dann kann ich mir
hier aus eben ganz kurz zu machen und
hier auch nochmal kurz ybbs jetzt habe
ich noch eine truhe highlight wird schon
rein passen das kann ich mir auf jeden
fall noch mal so ein paar sachen
reinpacken und erst mal sichern die
sache ist allerdings dass und das hab
ich auch schon gesagt ich nicht so
richtig weiß ob ich mich hier wirklich
zu hause fühlen
von hier sieht schön aus
mit dem dorf und man könnte erweitern
hier mit dem see aber ich bin noch ganz
ehrlich ich habe auch überhaupt noch
weiter herum zu laufen ich habe halt
diesem ort installiert bei uns oppland
ii durch die diese ganzen risiken berge
hinzugefügt wurden diese generell neuen
bio hier vorne mit den ganzen
einen mit der ganzen kohle hier mit
diesen abgegrasten landschaften hier
vorne seht ihr auch schon mit diesem
neuen bäumchen die ja auch so ein
bisschen nach savannah aussehen und ich
habe auch bock das ganze noch weiter zu
entdecken und ich habe so ein bisschen
hobel dem arsch bin ich ganz ehrlich ich
will mich jetzt nicht hier hin bauen und
mir eine riesige base aufbauen wenn ich
weiß dass 1000 blöcke weiter hier noch
gegen bienen fettes geiles wüsten bionis
mit irgendwelchen häusern oder hier
vorne ist im regenwald oder irgendwie so
wisst ihr wir haben möglichkeiten
und ich will das ausnutzen aber ihr
entscheidet meine lieben freunde wir
machen uns genauso wie in der vorletzten
folge ihr findet unten in den
kommentaren 2 kommentare ein kommentar
der hsh luca das ist schön hier baute
ich hierhin lass dich nieder und der
andere kommentar besagt dass ich noch
irgendwie weiter gehe beispielsweise in
die richtung hier vorne oder nach vorne
noch keine ahnung wohin dass ich das
ganze noch ein bisschen weiter entdecken
und mir dann halt einfach anschauen wo
will ich mich nie dafür bleiben erst
dann dort stehen mit unseren wichtigsten
sachen wohl wirklich wissen mensch hier
ist es geil hier will ich die ganze zeit
bleiben da kann ich mich auf ihren bauen
und dann da hinten und bleibe das ist
immer so weit auseinander und müssen
wenn man mit bahnen arbeiten und
eisenbahnstrecken
also stimmt ab und in den kommentaren
zeigt den kommentar was in der nächsten
folge sehen wollt die nächste folge geht
übermorgen online denn morgen kommt ein
neues motherboard video auf einem kanal
und ihr können generell jetzt erst mal
gerne einen daumen hoch unter dem video
hier da lassen wir es euch gefallen hat
abonniert einen kanal und trägt auch die
glocke wenn ihr dann die neue folge auch
nicht verpassen wollte
wir sehen uns überrollen
ich hoffe ihr stimmt ab dass wir
nirgendwohin laufen ich hab doch diese
welt zu entdecken
[Musik]